welcome William Shatner I will tell you
this probably seems more intimate than
you expected Jim Norton is on his way he
will join us on his way from hell well
you know so does he's been so to speak
he's a he's defecating it's defecates
defecating you know I didn't want to say
it in front of you you're something
serious come on I didn't yep probably I
mean is he in trouble
honestly he maybe I don't know has
anybody examined the consistency it was
defecation no we have interns for that
and so they'll go in when he's done just
just to make sure we have to check I've
got a new puppy I breed Dobermans mm-hmm
and and the thing you look for in a new
puppy she's 14 weeks old is what's his
poop like is that right yeah yeah no
it's just poop good yeah so their whole
conversations with my wife and it's the
poops all it's a little dry driving
should be more fluids of poop is that
what it is that does it tell you like
the quality of the puppy or just the
diet diet I mean okay and whether the
puppy is so your poop according to dr.
oz you know it should be deformed it
should be half circular really oh yeah
yeah
long law well long how as long as long
and the other questions yes how do you
measure it well that's exactly see so
you have a number of problems there
about length but color and consistency
right what and texture is also tough
because that's probably important but
the kids right you could lose your touch
right you observe the texture and not
too closely right right right right but
it's loop is very important so I speak
Jim Jim's back we were actually just
investing we look at your poop all the
way while I'm doing it we were talking
about health and how I'm doing and yeah
I always take down that's a twisted body
and flawed it is yeah yeah yeah but you
slide back you move the bag
land of the living here that's great I
always have to around this time it's the
double these coffees game a murder me
but look at that I think it cleans you
out pretty good yeah yeah yeah you're on
the air for so long you got only three
hours I just don't time it well do a lot
with what you ate last night yes so here
we are I've got a book out yes this is
this is incredible it's it's it's life
lessons that you've learned from your
life well yes or no right the book is
titled live long and dot dot dot ellipse
and that dot dot dot is the important
part of the title because you can live
long sure look at you but what are you
gonna do with it
right yeah what is prosper mean does
that mean riches monetarily or are you a
rich human being I view the richness of
the human being so that's what the book
is about
I also state very clearly in the book I
can't offer anybody any advice our poop
is all different sure it's true yeah so
how can I advise you what is good poop
and not because it's your poop it's
right and it's your body and if it's
good for you
that's good although there are universal
truth with poop blood in it bad news
that's true yes yes yes that's a very
valid point yeah there are universal
truths that don't not kill right okay
but and that's part of this book - right
and on principle
right and when do you compromise all
June generic questions that I sort of
talk about but no advice other than this
is what I did and this is what were
looted who knew that bowel movements
were such a great metaphor for life
everybody but you yeah that's right I
was so you've really honest in this book
- not that you haven't been in the past
but I was really shocked to read when
Leonard Nimoy passed away originally it
said like I have a charity event I
couldn't make it and I guess you would
just kind of keep
peace there what happened with you and
him because I was shocked to read that
you had a kind of falling out with him
yes I don't know what happened all I
know is that I had a charity event for
his funeral I couldn't go to the funeral
but I I'm not sure that would have been
welcome at this funeral anyway but I
couldn't go to the funeral and I and
what I did do though what I told the
audience
it so happens at mar-a-lago Red Cross
there were we raised millions of dollars
for the Red Cross that evening what I
did say to the people at the event was
that all our names and fame and all that
disappear so rapidly that it's
unconscionable
within weeks days months certainly years
the most famous of people are gone and
forgotten what is not forgotten our good
deeds because they reverberate they
don't have your name attached to it but
if you help somebody and that person
help somebody else that butterfly wing
effect takes place and for the rest of
time that good deed continues to
resonate but he stopped talking to you
for some reason yes I don't know why and
did you is there it has what point did
he yeah about a year before he died do
you just out of nowhere then so I mean
that's years after you've worked
together I mean you had this
relationship to your friendship yeah now
is there always a friendship or was it
casual because no we had so much in
common we our lives was strangely born
four days apart he was in Boston I was
in Montreal very similar cities he got
married about the same time divorce
children of the event the major events
of life happened to him as happened to
me and we helped each other was there
anybody and his family was I know if his
wife is still living moves or anybody
you could have asked in his family who
might have known huh yes and I never got
a satisfactory answer really what would
they tell you well because it's not
talked to his son and
some didn't do really quite know and and
he had stopped talking to his son for a
while so oh wow it was it was mysterious
and maybe there's something on I've
ceased to examine that be sure really no
answer and I've left I've let go of it
does it bug you that there are people
like George Takei for example has kind
of pushed this narrative that you're a
difficult guy right he said negative
things about you for a lot of years no
for since the beginning of I know this
guy 55 years ago I there I worked with
this gentleman day here in the day there
I I don't know him right and ever since
that moment nothing untoward ever
happened I didn't kick him in the balls
or anything what is problem is he's
bespoke but he has spoken badly of me
right for 55 satisfactory answer and and
and it just keeps you know he defames me
and I I keep trying to rise above it but
I'll have to kick him in the ball time
you actually saw him in person like as
close as you and I are a baby ten years
ago at an event and did you speak
pleasantly or not at all and not in his
direction and he trembled a little
is it do you just get to a point where
you're like in this life that I've led
people are just gonna develop opinions
about me
and I'm gonna have to just accept
absolutely I I saw something in the in
the some one of the tabloid newspapers
of me holding up a sign that I old and I
realized they had I'd hold up a sign for
for charity saying something charitable
I forgotten what it was they've scrubbed
the message inside and put another
another message that was not too kind
and I thought you know why am I even
looking at it it's ridiculous yeah they
can do that I think you just never hold
something up on the internet because
they're always going to see Michelle
Obama
they killed there yeah they had to see
it the whole like we'll get to get our
girls back and whatever so they just
kept erasing the sign and putting
different rows or when Trump held up the
the the you know the booklet they sign
and they did you know the folder or
whatever and they turned it into a
children's drawing they turned it into
like racist so that goes for people
saying nasty things about you that you
don't even know there's no point in
getting into it are you I'm sorry I said
are you know and again I've only I'm
gonna give you a bunch and you're a very
nice guy I've always like are you at
times a difficult guy probably but I
mean if you don't know somebody I mean
why would I be difficult why would you
speak ill of me we've known each other
over the years that I come in and do it
you why would you take that opportunity
yeah it's it's McCobb and and and ugly
and sick really and I don't I don't
bother with it and what I what I am
doing is writing books like live long
and dot dot we've said it before has
made no in music making music I've got
to come to music album out there right
now that you ought to listen to what
society you know it's called why not me
that's one of the songs on it and it's
with Jeff Cook of Alabama and it's
really good so I'm making music I'm
writing books
I'm on tour go to William Shatner calm
find out where I'll be at a city near
you like that I'm writing electric bikes
Pedigo bikes I'm involved in solar
Alliance so the solar power my outer
space calm the outer space dot-com go to
it and you'll find out what see there's
no you have no interest in just slowing
down and stopping all this well I have
slowed down this is slow down this is
crazy
slow down I mean I looked at a photo of
you on a horse recently I just won a
World Championship a couple of weeks ago
and I'm like I'm at 35 I'm like I'm
gonna ride any horses it's dangerous
it's ridiculous taking several bones
over the years why would you do this to
yourself because I love horses I I love
the art of being of riding a horse and
being with horses and breeding horses
and being with us is the same with dogs
I loved my dogs I love to breed them I
love to train them Oh dogs a Doberman
and and and actually I love people and
so cultivate people I love to talk to
you and and talk about anything you know
if I wasn't pushing a book we'd be
talking about defecation which I think
we do they're not mutually exclusive you
just like being active you love activity
well that's why we're alive yeah
lack of activities you're dead so the
book says say yes say yes to life at
what point in your life did you realize
you were at a place where you know what
I can impart some wisdom I've kind of
figured since I don't wanna I don't have
any wisdom I don't know what I'm talking
about
now know the the truth of what I've come
to understand is as you get older
nothing happens
you don't know anymore that you know
that that your defecation your poop is
important right so you'd take a look at
your poop cuz dr. Oz says your poop is
important right that's you know you yeah
that's about all you really know you
know what affects you I die I better not
do that because that makes me and and
all I can say like in the book this is
what I do if it resonates with you great
but if it doesn't don't do it because
nobody knows anything anyway at least of
all know anything about you so you don't
have the answers for everybody it's just
the answers for anybody if it helps
great if not okay okay certain the
interesting read yeah yeah and then do
you feel do you feel you talk about tank
like people ask you about tech all the
time tick yeah and I feel like you like
you were on a show called Star Trek
right and that has left you with this
lifelong pressure to be aware of what
technology is like you're playing a
character on a show and all of a sudden
you have to know about all that people
are asking you I was like Google
googling you last night and they were
like you know here's what we've chatted
or thinks about virtual reality here's
what and I was like my god this guy is
forced into having to keep up with
technology but but because I've did that
show I do shows I did a show last year I
think which I got to interview a lot of
cosmologists and
ended up with Stephen Hawking and I may
have done the last interview of Stephen
Hawking Wow
I talked to Stephen Hawking yeah you
know talk is a is communicated when I
communicate what's better but he spoke
to me through the computer and then
invited me for dinner and I went to
dinner to his house and I had done a
one-man show on Broadway some years ago
and I've toured with it and at dinner I
was required to speak and did parts of
the one mention in conversation with him
made him laugh and he would redden a
little he was highly intelligent as you
know Yanis intelligence was always there
his bright blue eyes sparkled but he
couldn't talk and he he couldn't feed
himself and it was it was an interesting
evening it is a little a lot of pressure
on you to carry the conversation
absolutely so I mean let your mind run
over what dinner with Stephen Hawking
would have been like now when you would
disi respond because I know under
computer he's probably faster than
anybody else would know with that it was
a laborious he had a monitor of a mouse
on his cheek on a muscle on his cheek he
was able to twitch the muscle on his
cheek and move the mouse why an spell
laborious Lee so that there was high
drama when I had asked him pre questions
pre preset and he had it already on this
computer so I would say ask him the
specific question I had to read from a
board so it was exactly what I sent him
months earlier and he press a button
with his cheek and and and that would
come this answer but he has said prior
to my engaging him was he had a question
for me and so I said and then the Giants
right what's your question for me and
laborious Lee with me looking on adding
to the drama you know I W you
and slowly I would like to know what
your favorite Star Trek episode was but
that's true and and like I say I made
him laugh and his laughter was a
reddening of the cheek and and sort of a
little this amazing guy what did he eat
it was more liquids rice more of a super
than and he had somebody feeding him
could he chew it all or no I don't think
so I don't think but he could swallow
right like he could actually I believe
that he could swallow could he see his
mouth did you it was your impression
that he would did he live a paned
existence or had he figured out how to
be as comfortable as a person can be in
that I don't know how you do that yeah
you know you read about people who were
in a coma yeah I can hear everything
yeah yeah they can't they can't
communicate and Terry Bradshaw with whom
I worked for two seasons in this
wonderful show that would we did
together on with George Foreman and Jeff
died yeah that's right Terry told me
about the time when he was piledrive Din
to the ground by a linebacker and he
couldn't move either there's something
had happened to his neck and he thought
it was paraplegic they took him off and
it took a day or two before the bruising
around his neck released enough so that
he got sensation back into his legs and
arms but for those two days he thought
it was a paraplegic and he wanted to die
but he could hear of course everything
that was going on just couldn't move
that sock it gives you an insight into
what somebody in a coma or is a
paraplegic and his unconscious would be
feeling like and I'm sure that that's
what dr. Stephen quadriplegic - like
below the neck below that families what
a waste
no I mean quadruple arms yeah yeah yeah
you're all being locked in they had that
like our friend you know patrice who you
did the lips with had a stroke and we
didn't know if he was or not but when
you walked into his hotel his hospital
room it said mr. o'neill may be able to
hear you even the doctors don't know
they don't know so it's such a horrible
all but four instances were people in
deep coma
have responded to stimuli press my hand
and they get pressure ends so they know
there's somebody in there
yeah that's crazy you get that kind of
insight on what Terry Bradshaw went
through and you'll still get on a horse
people get paralyzed on horses really
ice cream with whom after he had had
that accident after every rider that I
know including me for the next six
months every time we got up on a horse I
thought I wonder if this is my mom sure
yeah I went to visit with him and as I'm
walking through the glass doors at his
hospital he was at a hospital in New
Jersey and I'd flown in specifically and
I didn't know him I just know say hello
but I wanted to see him because of his
accident with the horses his love of
horses and I went in through the glass
doors I could see him waiting for me in
this wheelchair and they had a battery
wired to his chest that was breathing
for him and in that instant I thought oh
my god what am I gonna say what am I
gonna talk about right and the first
question he asked me was tell me about
your horses and we spent the whole time
talking about horses you know what it's
funny he had probably learned to do that
because he knew it's awkward because it
the first question anyone asks anyone
how you doing man oh it's a and it's
just it's such an odd question to ask a
guy in that condition so what are you
open with that's not this common
question well I mean how you doing but
the Canadian answer to that is not bad
it's such my sisters do that they live
in Canada they live in Montreal and
every time they do I said god sakes
is not bad good I mean if it's a bad is
it good yeah it's good well why don't
you say it's good so you know how to
just have conversations in those awkward
moments well I know you don't know I
mean it's always awkward but in that
particularly awkward moment he set me at
ease knowing probably that it would be
awkward he said tell me about your
horses and he did it speaking of awkward
so in you talk about a lot in this book
yeah
was there anything in the book because
you talk about really tough stuff with
your mom and and how that kind of shaped
your relationships going forward in a
pretty negative
way you talk about your ex-wife passing
away you talk about a lot of stuff that
you necessarily been super public about
before was there anything in this book
that you had second thoughts about that
you were like I don't know if I want to
go thing you know when you expose
yourself publicly your thoughts your
heart yeah it's it's tricky and you
think I wonder whether I should do this
or not
and the conclusion I came to was I'm
writing this book really in essence for
my family what will my grandkids who is
my grandfather all they have to do is
pick up this book or the some of the
other books that I've written oh that's
who he was that's you know people don't
know you really you're not gonna sit
down and talk about your mother
beyond if you're over 15 you're not
gonna it's I would the ballgame did fed
her to fade you know here I thought why
not why not take a mask down mm-hmm
hedge it and let it show for a while had
you dealt with it already or was writing
about it kind of like oh my god I'm
experiencing I don't know how you deal
with it is but becomes part whatever
Kurtwood your defecation this morning it
was a part of your journey in life now
yes you will you will never forget your
pooping this morning course not I taped
it everything we do is part of our
history and affects us how where the
we're different the next the moment
after we've had an experience or or
we've made a decision
we are different people and later on you
say I wonder if I should have made that
decision you couldn't help but make
whatever that decision was at that
moment because those were the forces
acting on but but sometimes you go back
and look at the decisions you go yeah I
made that in the moment for this reason
but then there's sometimes there's
regret and sometimes there's not the
moment you've made the decision you're
already different right yeah so you
having made the decision now you're a
different person you think well I wonder
if I should have made that decision
having
the decision you can't you you you have
to take responsibility for the person
you are at that moment and take
responsibility of the fact that you will
change change is the only thing that is
the constant at what point in your life
did you realize that your relationship
with your mom wasn't typical and she had
done you a disservice emotional I don't
think that she had done me anything
deliberately what do you say at that
moment would you love me more than you
lose somebody else you know you fumble
for an answer and and strangely that
answer stayed with me all these years
why I guess it really affected me but
nobody was out to harm it was a standard
answer what are you gonna say I love you
both the same so the quote was that
we're talking about is that you asked
your mom who do you love what do you
like seven years old yeah and you asked
your mom who do you love more me or
daddy right and she responded daddy cuz
he buys me things right and then saying
that's one of those but how how offhand
that must have been right you know
you're serving breakfast and you got the
things she half-kidding do you think or
did she
very possibly I mean I don't know but I
would think so but somehow they stuck
her through all those years or did it
come back to you twenty years or thirty
years later no it comes back you think
Wow there was a moment we were at
breakfast I remember they were sitting
on the chair and she was handing me some
cereal or something or other and I asked
her what every boy asks their mother at
some point in time and she flipped up
flipped and answered I mean wow amazing
yeah I asked my mother the answer was
not nice either oh really what did your
mom say
she also said daddy but because he was
better
[Laughter]
you know you can bring it out of anybody
you bring out anybody